[Music]
on this thursday night canada's top
military commander calls it
a day general jonathan vance is retiring
general vance's legacy is going to be a
long one why he's leaving
now the review ordered into the nova
scotia massacre the questions that need
answers
and why victims families fear they won't
get them
the campaign to outlaw conversion
therapy in the uk
i've been through it it nearly killed me
the push to protect and save lgbtq2
lives
and a name with a complicated past what
eskimo means
to canada's inuit people
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some developing news
involving the canadian armed forces the
country's top military commander the
chief of the defense staff jonathan
vance
who has served with the military for 39
years has announced he's retiring
in a letter informing the troops vance
thanked members for their service and
wrote
you have been the inspiration for my
life and i have given you my all
he said he intends to relinquish command
in the coming months
global's michael couture is with me from
ottawa mike do we know
why he's made this decision now well
donna we're hearing that general vance
was hoping to be considered for the job
as top soldier in nato a very
prestigious and powerful position when
that deadline
passed on july 16th and he was not
recommended by the liberal government
decided that it's time to step away i am
extremely disappointed
it was the first mission he led as chief
of the defense staff
and operation honor was likely one of
general vance's toughest
attempting to crack down on sexual
misconduct in the canadian military
the vance had been the cds since july
2015
appointed by then-prime minister stephen
harper
and he's been one of the longest serving
top soldiers in the country
he says he's planning to relinquish
command of the canadian armed forces
in the months to come in a statement to
his members vance said
you mean everything to canada you are
more important to the success of this
nation
than most will ever know and i am so
very proud to be counted
among your ranks general advance's
legacy is going to be a long one defense
analyst david perry says one of vance's
biggest accomplishments
was leading the defense review under
what some described
as a dovish liberal government it was a
far more pragmatic far more hard
edged and far more combat capable full
defense policy than you would have
expected just
reading the liberal platform in 2015. in
a statement prime minister justin
trudeau thanked vance for serving with
distinction at home
and around the world adding he has also
worked with the forces to make them more
inclusive
and representative of the country they
defend and the canadians they protect
a nod to general vance's efforts recruit
more women and lgbtq2 canadians into the
military
and that could be where the government
looks for vance's replacement
i would be shocked if at least one of
the two
i believe still currently serving
three-star female generals in the
canadian armed forces weren't at least
giving consideration
general vance will remain cds until his
successor is named a process that the
pio
pmo says could take months donna
michael couture in ottawa thank you more
than three months after the mass
shooting in nova scotia provincial and
federal officials have announced a joint
review of what happened that deadly day
22 people were killed by a gunman and
their families have been demanding
answers
it's not clear the process announced
today will deliver them
the review will not have the power to
compel witnesses to testify
and the information collected to prepare
the report will be kept confidential
alicia drouse reports the federal and
nova scotia governments have appointed a
three-person panel to review the
circumstances of april's shooting spree
their review will include
a comprehensive look into the causes
context and the circumstances
that gave rise to the terrible and
tragic events it's aimed at looking into
the gunman and his past
the involvement of gender-based and
intimate partner violence
as well as the rcmp's response and
communications with the public
victims and their family but the review
will not have any ability to compel
witnesses to testify under oath
i believe that there's questions that
have to be answered
and i think they need to be answered
under oath a public inquiry would hold
more power which is what many had been
calling for
and just a day before this review was
announced hundreds including family
members of the victims
marched demanding a public inquiry all
the families
all support this and we want a public
inquiry
and we don't want a probe we don't want
analyzed we want a public inquiry
the tragedy left 22 people dead over a
span of nearly 100 kilometers and has
raised numerous questions
from how the gunman was able to obtain
weapons and why warning signs of the
gunman's violent past slipped through
the cracks
to why residents in the area weren't
alerted to the fact a gunman was on the
loose
we've heard the calls for answers and
know that the survivors
families of the victims and the broader
public
want a process to get answers while
minister fury indicated a review was
chosen so victims families wouldn't be
re-traumatized
a statement on behalf of the families
released thursday called the review
disappointing
saying they want to participate not be
protected
still both governments say they
considered all options
but decided a review would be most
appropriate we have an opportunity for
for an earlier approach
earlier resolutions and
a greater opportunity to make change
much quicker than we could through the
inquiry process
alicia droves global news halifax
now to the pandemic we are watching the
case numbers here in canada closely as
public health officials warn of an
uptick in infections across the country
today more than 430 new cases were
reported most were in canada's four
largest provinces
quebec ontario alberta and british
columbia
cases are also rising in saskatchewan
more on that
in a moment first though new numbers
from the canadian blood services give
some insight into how many canadians
remain vulnerable to covet 19.
10 000 blood samples were tested for
antibodies to the novel coronavirus
antibodies indicate past infection fewer
than one percent of those samples had
covid19 antibodies which means the vast
majority of canadians
remain vulnerable to infection since the
virus has not vanished it means the more
we come into contact with other people
the more
it will spread outbreaks will have to be
managed for a long time to come
mike delay looks at how that is likely
to happen
19 was waiting for this the combination
of warm weather and months of isolation
frustration
where physical distancing was ignored
outbreaks have been declared
in calgary 14 at one bar 23 at another
and a private party saw 44 people walk
out infected
and it's not just alberta bc and ontario
are seeing similar spikes
so is the solution as simple as this
just hold off on these parties i i don't
know
where everyone wants to party so badly
but enough
it was early may when canada hit its
peak for new cases
what followed was a steady two-month
decline but in july after all those
parties
we saw a rise in positive tests covet 19
isn't going away still there doesn't
appear to be public support or the
political will to shut everything down
again
in terms of approach that would be the
hammer when a scalpel is what's needed
i encourage everyone to be the voice of
compassion
and reason and to call out your friends
if they're
not feeling well and they want to go out
with you to show those around you you
care
have safe social interactions with fewer
faces
and larger spaces so epidemiologists are
now emphasizing the basics
testing contact tracing wearing masks
and physical distancing
while accepting that one set of rules
doesn't work for everyone
in bc officials hope they averted a
major outbreak after partygoers in
kelowna caught the virus
before traveling around the province a
thousand people
are now in self-isolation and when
covid19 hit saskatchewan's heart right
communities
officials put strict restrictions on
travel to and from the colonies
both instances where the wider
population is protected
but not overly impacted if we try to
keep
everyone under a single simple
sort of rule we are going to wind up
with a situation that i think would be
very
challenging to maintain for a long
period of time
so going forward it appears the
provinces will focus on finding a
balance
because covet 19 isn't going away
anytime soon
mike drolite global news toronto
we're getting a better sense tonight of
how many passengers on flights to and
from canada may have been exposed to
covet 19
according to the public health agency of
canada at least 561 flights between
february 4th and july 18th
at either confirmed or suspected cases
on board the majority of the affected
flights were in march that's before the
border restrictions were put in place
in the past two months though there's
been an uptick in potential exposure on
board airplanes arriving at
and departing from canadian airports
the us has reached yet another alarming
milestone more than 4 million people
there
have now tested positive for covid19
this gives you a sense of how fast the
crisis is escalating in the u.s
according to reuters it took 98 days to
reach 1 million confirmed cases
43 more days to hit 2 million just 27
days later the u.s hit 3 million and in
the span of
16 days cases have now jumped
to 4 million as case numbers rise so too
is america's
death toll from covid 19. as of tonight
more than 143
000 people in the u.s have died and that
is by far
the most people who have died in any
country in the world
the images coming out of portland oregon
every night are
dystopian federal agents in camouflage
and with no id
facing off against increasingly defiant
protesters
last night the city's mayor was one of
them
ted wheeler was tear gassed outside the
federal courthouse where
fires had been started the mayor said
federal agents sent by president trump
are not welcome
but he was jeered by protesters for not
reigning in
local police they believe if he had
federal agents may not have been sent in
to quell the protests about racial
injustice
and police brutality president trump is
sending federal agents to other american
cities hundreds of agents are being
deployed to chicago and albuquerque new
mexico
trump claims there have been outbursts
of violence in the democrat-led
cities and blames the so-called radical
left he said he intends to expand his
crackdown to other cities as well
chicago's mayor is cautiously accepting
the agents for now but warns the city
will take the president to court if
there are any unconstitutional actions
critics say it's all a political ploy by
the president and part of his
re-election
strategy coming up we look at that as an
election campaign strategy how law and
order
and race play in 2020
a widely discredited so-called therapy
has been used for decades to try to
change a person's sexual orientation
it's called conversion therapy and
though it may seem like a relic of the
past
it is still legal and practiced in many
countries
canada's federal government has
introduced legislation to criminalize it
and now british prime minister boris
johnson is promising to do the same
as crystal demancing reports the
pressure is coming from young people
demanding change monroe bergdorf an
actress model and
transgender activist is known for using
social media to engage on important
issues
recently bergdorf along with elton john
dualipa and
others used their social media power to
highlight the ongoing practice of
conversion therapy in the uk
and a petition to stop it it's amazing
in a way that we've seen this
groundswell of support but at the same
time the reason we've seen this
groundswell
is because the government hasn't taken
action yet
the petition putting the issue back in
the spotlight and hopefully on the
government's radar was started by a 15
year old
in the quran there's a quote that says
all those who believe
stand firm for justice even when it's
against your own people
and i read that a couple days also
before i started position that also kind
of struck me the fact that
we're supposed to be signing up for each
other's rights no matter who we are
where we come from
or what our background is many religious
groups are coming together in support of
the ban
three years ago it was the church of
england that first issued the call for
change there are many forms of
conversion therapy including
psychotherapy
exorcism and corrective rape
proponents have positioned it as a cure
for a person's sexual orientation
or to suppress their gender identity our
human rights go as far as
the fact that we we don't do harm and
when we know that
we're committing harm and we know the
mental
anguish that we put so many of us i've
been through it it nearly killed me
research suggests those who have been
through it are more likely to try and
end their lives the health consequences
were part of the reason theresa may's
government in 2018
committed to ending the practice the
current administration
says that everyone should be able to
freely live their lives
safely many advocates say
a rise in nationalism has led to more
intolerance recently
putting the lgbtq2 community at even
greater risk
there's been some very unhelpful
politics going on in the background
and i for one i'm speaking out now
because i'm extremely concerned
concerned that is every day passes
vulnerable members of society
are still unprotected and there are only
a few days left in the current session
of parliament
crystal gomez and global news london
from nixon to now still ahead tracing
the republican strategy to combat crime
in the u.s
you're watching global national
[Music]
for decades in the u.s politicians have
used a law and order agenda layered with
issues of race to try to win over voters
in the late 60s richard nixon promised
to restore order to american life
and president donald trump is running a
law and order campaign in 2020
though the phrase is the same as eric
sorenson explains the context today
is different the unhinged left-wing mob
is trying to vandalize our history as
u.s president donald trump
sounds off over cultural divisions in
america it is not something new in
republican politics
the silent majority is stronger
than ever before the great
silent majority of my fellow americans
you can almost draw a straight line from
nixon to trump the silent majority which
was
nixon's way of sort of saying most
americans at least most white americans
quietly agree with my positions they're
both
playing on sort of white working class
racial grievances
white grievances in modern america can
be traced in part to this
i'm about to sign into law
the civil rights act of 1964. when
democratic president lyndon johnson
sought to end segregation and
discrimination
it was a landmark achievement for black
americans but also an opportunity for
republicans to realign american politics
especially in the south it is the voice
of the great majority of americans
from nixon on a message that seized on
the fears of white americans
they're not racist or sick often
emphasizing issues like law and order
ronald reagan addressed that head on
before he was president
they would inform you that law and order
were code words that really met a call
for racial discrimination
bush and dukakis on crime this ad helped
george h.w bush who was trailing
to beat democrat michael dukakis for the
presidency he allowed first-degree
murderers to have weekend passes from
prison
one was willie horton they're trying to
appeal to the concerns of voters
without directly and explicitly
appealing to to racism because
american voters also don't generally
want to consider themselves
racist massive illegal immigration by
2016
following the first black president
donald trump revived the grievances of
many white voters
and we will take back this country for
you and we will make america great again
and now in 2020 the black lives matter
protests and the removal of confederate
statues represent a natural target for
trump these people are vandals but
they're agitators
but they're really they're terrorists
only this year is different
black lives matter was painted in front
of the white house
and later in front of trump tower as
protests defied the president
it's clear a much broader coalition is
standing up
for racial equality our president today
uh you know he's
not really helping with the cause he's
not really hearing about equal rights
for all people
they are aware of how the republican
party is perceived this former gop
strategist says trump is out of touch
with the change happening in america
what is his reelection message it cannot
be a grievance politics
that does not give a promise for
tomorrow we are the party of
law and order those words have worked
for republicans for 50 years
but in 2020 many americans are embracing
a new message
racial justice eric sorenson global news
next the complicated history of the word
edmonton cfl team
just dropped
we are proud to give you the seattle
kraken
there it is seattle's new nhl team is
called the kraken after the legendary
sea monster it's the 32nd
team to join the nhl's roster the new
logo
is an s-shaped tentacle it's a nod to
the seattle metropolitans who won the
stanley cup back in
1917. choosing a team name isn't simple
seattle started out with about 1200
options
it's tricky because the words we choose
matter and as we've seen with the
washington redskins and the edmonton
eskimos
names chosen years ago do not always
stand the test of time
heather europe's west reports when she
was born in apex hill nunavut
this inuit community elder was given the
name nalak by her mom and dad
but later she would be given a second
identity by the canadian government
not a name but a number on a brown
leather
eskimo tag my personal e-number is
e71866 colonization came late for the
people of canada's far
north la drew was a child when she saw
her way of life
suddenly change i was brought up
culturally
hunting fishing camping
on the tundra
where where my parents were
born and raised until
colonizing colonization came
colonization brought a number of painful
policies to inuit communities
many were forced to relocate or sent to
residential schools
and there was something else there was
at one time every family had a whole dog
team
and now almost none of them do whether
there was a coordinated order by the
government to kill the sled dogs is
still a subject of debate
but for the drew who was six years old
at the time
the memory is as vivid as it is dark i
witnessed the dog slaughter
because my father himself had a dog team
they hired a relative of
ours to slaughter
our dogs i have talked to elders who
have said you know that
more than almost any other history that
was the darkest time because
it meant that anyway couldn't leave
their
the communities that they'd been settled
into not all inuit including la drew
feel the term eskimo
is derogatory but she's happy to hear
edmonton's cfl
team is dropping the name and that's
because on game days when the edmonton
eskimos took to the field
there was a disconnect and all of that
painful complicated context
was lost it does i think detract from
our humanity when we are
turned into a mascot what i would like
people to understand
is we are human beings just like they
are not a number or a mascot but naloch
an enoch woman her parents named in a
beautiful part of canada's north
heather eurex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's york canada is the village of
harry's harbor newfoundland and labrador
it first appeared in the census in
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye